NOW, NEIL.
>> Neil: ALL RIGHT, JACQUI.
THANKS.
HAVE A GOOD WEEKEND.
JACQUI AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
LET'S GO TO DR. JULIE A MEMBER
OF THE CDC ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO
THE DIRECTOR OF ROBERT WOOD
JOHNSON FOUNDATION VICE
PRESIDENT.
DOCTOR, IF I CAN START WITH A
MORE GENERAL QUESTION.
SOME CONFUSION AS TO WHETHER
COVID IS HERE TO STAY.
MANY MEDICAL EXPERTS SAY IT WILL
BE PART OF OUR LIVES LIKE THE
FLU SHOT.
WHERE ARE YOU ON THIS?
>> IT'S POSSIBLE THAT COVID IS
HERE TO STAY.
IT LOOKS LIKE THAT IS POSSIBLE.
I'D SAY WHEN PEOPLE ARE
ANSWERING THE QUESTION, SHOULD
WE ACCEPT IT AS THE NORMAL?
WHAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING AS
OMICRON IS NOT SOMETHING TO
ACCEPT AS THE NEW NORMAL.
WE HAVE INCREDIBLY HIGH RATES OF
DISEASE, WITH MANY PEOPLE BEING
HOSPITAL ICED AND YOUNG CHILDREN
BEING HOSPITALIZED.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE WANT
TO LIVE WITH WE HAVE TO OPTIMIZE
INTERVENTIONS AND OPTIMIZE
TRANSMISSION AND DISEASE.
>> Neil: WITH OMICRON, ONE OF
THE THINGS I FIND STARTLING
ABOUT, THIS WE HAVE FOUR MILLION
CASES IN THE PAST WEEK VERSUS
FOUR MILLION CASES IN THE FIRST
SIX MONTHS OF THE PANDEMIC.
WE'RE TOLD THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF THESE CASES ARE
RELATIVELY MILD BY COMPARISON.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> YEAH.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE TELLING US
RIGHT NOW.
INCREDIBLY HIGH SURGE OF
DISEASES, PEOPLE GETTING SICK.
COMPARE THE NUMBER OF CASES TO
THOSE BEING HOSPITALIZED AND
THOSE DYING, THE NUMBERS DON'T
COMPARE.
IT'S CLEAR PEOPLE ARE NOT
GETTING AS SICK OR HOSPITALIZED
LIKE THEY DID IN PRIOR WAYS OF
THE PANDEMIC.
THAT'S NOT TO SAY IT'S NOT
SERIOUS.
THE TOTAL NUMBERS ARE SO HIGH OF
PEOPLE GETTING SICK.
OUR HOSPITAL SYSTEMS ARE
STRESSED AND WE HAVE TO TAKE
THIS SERIOUSLY.
>> Neil: YOU KNOW, THE NEW
VARIANT, SHOULD WE BE WORRIED
ABOUT THAT?
>> THROUGHOUT THIS PANDEMIC,
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS THE EMERGENCE
OF VARIOUS VARIANTS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KEEP AN EYE ON
THEM.
WE HAVE TO KNOW IF IT CAUSES
SERIOUS DISEASE.
THE OTHER QUESTION IS HOW
EFFECTIVE ARE TREATMENTS AND
PREVENTION MEASURES IN
PREVENTING TRANSMISSION OF THE
VARIANTS.
SO KEEP A CLOSE EYE ON WHAT IS
HAPPENING AND EMERING AND
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS TO KNOW HOW
BEST TO RESPOND.
>> Neil: DOCTOR, MODERNA'S CEO
SAID THAT THERE MAY BE A NEED
FOR A FOURTH COVID SHOT.
THIS COMES AT THE SAME TIME THAT
ISRAEL INSTITUTED AN ADDITIONAL
BOOSTER.
FOUR SHOTS IN ALL TO DEAL WITH I
GUESS EVERYTHING FROM THE
ORIGINAL COVID, DELTA AND THE
REST, THE OMICRON.
BUT WHERE DOES IT END?
HOW MANY SHOTS?
HOW MANY BOOSTERS?
>> NEIL, THIS GOES BACK TO THE
QUESTION THAT YOU ASKED ME.
IS COVID HERE TO STAY?
WE DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION.
IF THE VIRUS CIRCULATES AND WE
HAVE NEW VARIANTS THAT ARE
EMERGING, VACCINATION MAY BE
PART OF OUR ANNUAL ROUTINE LIKE
FLU VACCINE.
IT'S TOO EARLY TO SAY THAT AT
THIS POINT.
WHEN MODERNA'S CEO IS TALKING
ABOUT A FOURTH DOSE, WE COULD BE
TALKING ABOUT ADDITIONAL
BOOSTERS AND COULD BE A
DIFFERENT FORM OF THE VACCINE
THAT PROTECTS AGAINST DIFFERENT
VARIANTS.
AT THIS POINT IT'S SPECULATION
AND TOO EARLY.
>> Neil: THANKS, DR. MORITA AND
ANSWERING THESE QUESTIONS.
I JUST WANTED TO KNOW.
YOU HAD ANSWERS FOR ALL OF THEM.
MUCH